[Music]
jessica is in dallas hi jessica how are
you
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um i have something that
i we just cannot figure our way out of
it and it's probably easier for you to
explain it to us
we have bought a house about three years
ago
decided on um installing solar panels
adding to the debt and
we do not make
but maybe
30 100 a month after child support
we
do not know which way is up we do not
know how to make ends meet
i've tried to start a stay-at-home
business while i stay at home with my
son and we are just
upside down on a lot of things um
what do you owe on the solar panels
they were just installed last year so
that's about thirty thousand dollars
what is what do you owe in your house
we know about 197.
okay what's your house worth
uh
per open door it's worth about 300. okay
what other data have you got
we have about 15 grand in credit card
debt set because we try to make uh
make remodeling things happen when we
bought the house that didn't work
um
so yeah so so of course i just don't
want to respond to you on your cars
my stepdaughter we don't owe anything on
cars we're renting to own from a friend
of ours but we may likely just have to
give them back the car
so you have two cars
we actually have three cars one was
gifted to us so there's no reason to
have the third
that's why we might just give it back
okay so you have one that's paid for one
that and or you have two that's paid for
and one that's rent to home
correct yeah give it back today
yeah you're right you're today no i'm
not kidding it was not a joke no you're
right now yeah we we just discussed that
this morning before i can give you a
call okay um aside from that uh like i
said i i'm getting 3 000
take-home pay
three thousand dollars how many kids
have you got
uh we have one child at home and then my
stepdaughter
and then your stepdaughter what
your stepdaughter is not at home
you mean you have partial custody with
her
partially yes okay all right let's see
and how old's your baby that's at home
he's three
okay
all right and your husband works outside
the home and you've been trying to do
stuff from home
yes sir okay how old are you guys 30
that sounds nice
about 36. okay all right
well i knew you was right in there
somewhere based on the mission
okay
let's back up a second and let's look at
the whole thing
okay all right there's like four things
that jump out at me on these
conversations so far
okay
one is
you guys have to
lock arms
and write down a pledge in blood that
says i'm going to quit buying crap i
can't afford
solar panels
renovations
anything ever unless i can pay cash for
it i'm never buying it again agreed
agreed because you have impulsed
yourself into a corner
you're right
unwise purchases that put you in a
corner
right okay now that's thing one that
jumps out at me uh i think thing two is
then the two of you are going to sit
down and also start a budget and we're
going to help you i'm going to put you
into ramsey plus into financial peace
university and every dollar if you
promise me that you and your husband
will do everything i teach you to do you
can turn this around
oh absolutely i'm desperate the other
the other thing we're going to do is i'm
going to send you a copy of ken
coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
so that both of you can begin to work on
your careers
because neither one of you are
maximizing your incomes
correct you can both make more money
okay and that would help
that would that would be amazing yeah i
mean you should double your income
really in the next year yeah between you
being more effective at what you're
doing from home and between him
rethinking his whole career strategy
absolutely okay absolutely and lastly
you can have a whole lot of peace
just breathe
it in
that if none of that works
just sell the house
yes that was what i jumped to at first
yeah and it cleared it clears everything
you're 100 debt free get you a little
rental you and your little
three-year-old
and you guys restart fresh
all your mistakes are covered by the
equities in the sale of the house you
get a fresh start i'd rather you didn't
do that
i'd rather you get your income up and
pay off 45 000 worth of debt 15 credit
card 30 solar panels and keep you paid
for cars and living on a budget you can
probably do that if you can get your
income up
i'd rather you keep the house
it's a better long-term it's a better
long-term plan
it sure is i i don't want to move i
don't want to find a new house i don't
want to put money down but you're not
you're not you're not so far in the
corner that you can't get out
right
we can always play this card
if we get cornered
right sell the house okay that's our
last that's our last chance so what i'm
what i always do is this here's what i'm
doing with you and i do it with myself
and george we talk about this a lot in
financial coaching as well if you can
analyze your worst case scenario
and kind of emotionally swallow that and
let it get down in your stomach
and that's your worst case scenario and
and you accept it
then everything from theirs up
yeah everything's easier after that yeah
so
i know
i would cry a little but i could sell
the house and this whole thing would be
over
and so
really at that point
any other thing i try is a better plan
right right you know so okay you're okay
in other words in other words jessica
you're okay breathe you're okay
you're just behind you're in a monopoly
game and you're not winning right now
and you need to go around and pass go
and collect 200 you know
you're at baby step zero where we decide
that we're not going further into debt
we're going to stop digging this hole
that's a big deal and then we've got to
start baby step one and two and start
paying off the debt and you can do this
i mean this is not
an emergency scenario it feels like your
back is against the wall but it's just
because you can't see the forest from
the trees right now well you have
absolutely no idea where what little
money is coming in is going
you're so freaking chaotic and out of
control right now that when you sit down
and actually start doing a budget that's
also going to give you a sense of power
fabulous that sounds wonderful and so
you're it's not going to fix everything
tomorrow but you're going to go oh crap
we really can because george and i have
done enough budgets that we can look at
these numbers and go i could do that you
can do that you can do that but yours is
so frazzled and it's going off in 46 000
directions
that it's hard for you to go
i mean we actually have more belief in
your situation than you do at this
moment
you
do please turn off every screen in your
talk to sure
house because there's going to be
another infomercial selling you on
another thing and more solar and credit
cards just turn off the screens and get
real focused on this debt you can do
this okay so i'm going to send you i'm
going to send you the tools to do it i'm
going to send you the tools to do it
kelly's going to pick up we're going to
get you signed up for financial peace
university and ramsey plus it's going to
give you the every dollar app you get
you and your husband sit down tonight
turn off put the kid to bed turn off all
the tv sit down start working this
budget
turn that car back to that friend
cut up your credit cards and start the
class and i'm also going to ship you ken
coleman's book because we're going to
start having discussions about both of
you making more money which will solve
this
but again the career has kind of been
running on
default
just whatever comes that's what i do
instead of by plan and anytime you run
something by default you're running at
about 30 efficiency versus plan
execution of a detailed long-term game
plan will get you closer to 100
efficiency
and but when you just let everything
everything's just kind of been happening
to y'all and we're gonna turn this
around you're gonna start happening to
it that's right intentionality and
here's what's amazing about doing that
budget the first time you do it you want
to throw up because you realize how much
money you've wasted and what i thought
we were spending 200 on food and then
you start to do a budget get on a plan
start tracking it slim things down and
you feel that hope that's what this is
about all right so kelly paycheck to
purpose and ramsey plus we're going to
take care of you jessica you called me
back any time
you get scared we will walk with you
through this
we know you can do this if we can
convince you to go do it